[Musique]
allez c'est halloween est aujourd'hui
dans la bataille des couples pour
l'occasion il a décidé de faire peur à
la langue française et will survive
wallace et c'est le moment
visiblement une personne n'a emmené deux
dictionnaires sur leur dit vous allez
voir ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde
c'est parti oui c'est certain
ok il va avoir trois phases du cycle 1
en premier l'alsace est exquis ni
pulvérisation restauration canalisations
définit les connards marre d une morte
avec bach
alors voilà c'est bon la langue
française ou s'il a été assassiné alors
j'aimerais faire un petit coin wafa oui
c'est la cousine de wifi vous ne savez
pas tu lancé un petit défi à wafa je lui
ai dit la prochaine fois que tu es dans
crise de couple essaie de passer
discrètement cinq fois en fait en moins
de 5 secondes et ben wafa l'a fait
regarde moi en fait j'ai pas menti
depuis le début je peux pas trahir en
fait
en fait je sais je sais pas faire je
suis venu en fait je comprends pas alors
on peut participer à la bataille des
couples c'est il ya des risques qu'une
candidate peut avoir de gros problèmes
d' équilibre un animateur peut perdre un
tibia en direct ou mieux un candidat
peut avoir envie de faire la grosse
commission aux pires moments du jeu
ouais je vous le dis aux vidéos
regardées
[Musique]
rageur
alicia
sauf tendance à voir sa coop la bataille
des coups sûrs qu'ils assurent qu'ils
regardent la bataille des coûts
franchement même en suis je regarde bien
c'est marrant c'est vous n'en connaissez
beaucoup de nos quelques soient pas tout
je reconnais plus dans l'axé les unes
dans les normes et marseille exacto
alors c'est assez rare pour le signaler
mais nos amis dylan et fidji ont eu un
éclair de lucidité vous savez que ces
victimes se sont bien protégés sont
rendu compte qu'ils perdaient toutes les
épreuves intellectuelles et une hausse
au niveau perd toutes les épreuves
intellectuelles à cause de nos deux de
nos lacunes en français
enfin c'est pas exactement français
regardez je pense pas qu'on ait brillé
sur le parcours clairement je pense
qu'avant de venir au stade en tueur on
aurait dû au format la fac pour tous les
enfants qu'ils écoutent aller à l'école
c'est important
puis j'ai moi on va se cacher en
annulant dit et en irlande en
orthographe ihu
[Musique]
je n'aborde pas ses sympathies radine je
sais que ça t'énerve non ça ne m'énerve
pas mais moi je trouve que c'est dommage
ce nivellement vers le bas
votre fille elle a quel âge à la saison
elle regarde au point mais alors pas du
tout elle a pas envie de regarder ou
voulu ou non non pas du tout ça
l'intéresse pas pas du tout l'adulte et
je me demande comment c'est possible moi
j'ai arrêté l'école à 15 ans ça je le
fais porte aux graves à inventer ou ça
peut revenir grâce à être extrait pour
passer dans l'échiné du casque d'or dont
l'ue fait des interviews et des pare-feu
graphie bien sûr le style a parlé comme
ça donc c'est enfin selon eux c'est
rigolo non mais c'est vrai moi aussi je
pense qu'ils préparent des mailles bien
sur nos talons hauts talons
merci en tout cas alors on les oublie
pas rassurez vous les bars et w9 sont
bien là on les kiffe je vous présente
mon nouveau chouchou c'est greg craig
j'ai un scoop à vous donner il est
atteint d'une maladie très rare c'est là
julien lepers it aiguë ça veut dire qu'à
n'importe quel moment sans prévenir il
peut partir au wawel regarder
[Applaudissements]
la séquence devient de plus en plus
culte parce qu'il me semble que greg a
partagé d'une séquence un extrait de thé
pmp on parle de lui et dylan le fait
pratiquement tous les soirs
tous les soirs sur instagram sur
snapshot je sais pas il filme son écran
parce qu'il est de vente et pmp et
montre qu'on parle des voitures mais moi
je kiffe lieu-dit la wii mais aussi vous
adore il vous embrasse il était là la
soirée dadjo aussi j'aurais à battre
l'as d'or franchement je l'adoré des
coûts - toulouse et mais là bas ma mère
horizon beaucoup alors faire un ezio à
ma mère vous andré maes entre merci ben
alors on va pas se mentir greg chin chin
de te de partout franchement il est
surtout les buy et passe ses journées à
tenter des trucs avec toutes les meufs
et là il est persuadé d'avoir une touche
avec mélanie donc il attend de se
retrouver en croisière il se pose à côté
d'elle et commence à lui ouvrir son
coeur le problème c'est que mélanie elle
et pas comme une housse chaud le besoin
de quelqu'un qui analyse en thaïlande et
bien sûr de moi j'aime pas coller j'aime
pas toi j'aime faire des attentions
le mec très fragile c'est gerbino
connaître plus plus plus
j
[Applaudissements]
sur lui